note that the sum of angles within a
triangle is 180 degrees let's prove that
for triangle ABC to prove that we need
to do a small bit of construction we
draw a line EF passing through point a
and parallel to BC it will look like
this it passes through point a and is
parallel to BC you can see that many
angles are formed let's name them
let this be angle one let this be angle
two and let this be angle three angles
one two and three are the interior
angles of the triangle and the sum
equals 180 degrees there are two more
angles that are formed outside the
triangle let's call them angle for an
angle five before we move forward let us
understand a new concept assume these
are two parallel lines and there is a
transversal that cuts those lines
let this be angle four and this be angle
two in such a case angle two will always
equal angle 4 these are alternate
interior angles
remember the transversal has to cut two
parallel lines now let's zoom out and
look at the original figure BC and EF
are parallel lines and angle 2 and angle
4 are alternate interior angles which is
why angle 2 will equal angle 4 if you
look at the figure carefully you will
notice that angle 3 and angle 5 are
alternate interior angles to AC is the
transversal which intersects these two
parallel lines it means that angle 3
will also be equal to angle 5 both these
pairs are alternate interior angles what
we are interested in is the sum of these
three angles angle 1 plus angle 2 plus
angle 3 since angle 2 is equal to angle
4 and angle 3 is equal to angle 5
we can write this as angle one plus
angle four plus angle five we just
replaced angles two and three with
angles four and five what does this tell
you look at the figure and see where
angles one four and five are placed EF
is a straight line and since EF is a
straight line we know that the sum of
angle 1 angle 4 and angle 5 will equal
180 degrees it implies that the sum of
angles one two and three will also equal
180 degrees
you
you